[Musique]
les règles élémentaires de la prudence
nous enseigne que quand on est sur la
route et qu'on veut doubler
on va regarder dans le rétroviseur
même chose quand il s'agit de la marche
de l'histoire
quand une nation veut dépasser se
dépasser en accomplissant une révolution
elle doit regarder dans le rétroviseur
c'est à dire son histoire sinon elle
risque d'être percutée de plein fouet
par un objet roulant à grande vitesse et
qu'elle n'a pas vu venir
l'histoire comme vous le savez est
impitoyable entend l'ignorent dans la
négligent
elle peut se venger violemment de nous
elle est capable de faire surgir parmi
nous les monstres du passé ils se
déchaînent nous terrorisent et finissent
par nous prendre en otage
j'ai réalisé cela un jour dont je me
souviens très bien il ya toujours un
instant t c'était l'après midi du
vendredi 14 septembre 2012
quand un groupe
d'illuminer a attaqué l'ambassade des
états unis à tunis pour y mettre le feu
à cause d'un film américain la ligne le
sens de l'islam qui portent atteinte à
la mémoire du prophète
j'étais abasourdi par ce spectacle
bien sûr ce n'était pas la première fois
que je voyais une manifestation de la
violence religieuse mais c'était la
première fois que je la voyais
directement et non sur l'écran de mon
téléviseur
je me suis dit qui sont ces gens là ils
vont à la mort ils sèment la mort pour
venger l'honneur bafoué du prophète et
puis qui est le prophète
qu'est ce que je sais de lui qu'est ce
que je sais de l'islam à grand chose
pour ne pas dire rien du tout et je
voyais au dessus de l'ambassade des
états unis
une épaisse fumée noire qui m'a semblé
comme la matérialisation de mons de mon
ignorance de notre histoire de
l'histoire de l'islam une religion qui a
toujours fait partie de ma vie mais qui
commençait à me devenir étrangères
évidemment nous connaissons tous cet
islam visible des foyers il a pour moi
le visage serein et pieux de ma grand
mère
et bien cet islam là était en train de
muter de devenir une arme pointée sur
nous par des fanatiques de devenir un
outil de propagande politique au service
d'aventuriers en quête de pouvoir
alors j'ai décidé de comprendre je ne
voulais pas rester l'observatrice
passive est indigné de ce spectacle
morbide et j'ai décidé de faire comme
ces illuminés et de lancer un assaut pas
assurent une ambassade
bien sûr mais sur cette forteresse
quelle histoire de l'islam j'étais
persuadé que la connaissance du passé
pouvait me donner des clés pour
comprendre le présent et là j'ai fait un
peu comme marcel proust
toutes proportions gardées et je suis
parti à la recherche du temps perdu
vous savez content se sont égarés le
premier réflexe qu'on a c'est de revenir
au point de départ à la source et j'ai
commencé à lire des livres les plus
anciens de la tradition musulmane
évidemment et naturellement je me suis
intéressé de près aux personnages clés
de cet islam d origine ne prophète
mohamed
l'expérience a été passionnante plus je
lisais et plus cette fumée noire épaisse
se dissiper le le personnage mythique
lointain du prophète sortait
progressivement de la pénombre il
s'approchait devenait plus humain et
j'étais particulièrement interpellé par
la dernière phase de sa vie une période
particulièrement intéressante et riche à
plus d'un titre d'abord l'homme est mort
triste malheureux
malmené par son entourage et ceci a créé
avec lui une relation d'en pâtir
la dimension tragique
que j'ai perçu chez lui lui a même donné
un surplus d'humanité et puis là c'est
une chose que tout le monde connaît la
mort du prophète a constitué à un moment
décisif dans l'histoire de l'islam car
durant cette période
la question cruciale de sa succession a
été posée violemment opposés et nous
savons tous que cette question est la
matrice de tous les conflits de tous les
problèmes qui déchire les musulmans
depuis 14 siècles et il y avait autre
chose quelque chose qui m'a fasciné dans
les derniers jours de mohamed c'est la
part d'énigme qui entoure cette période
et qui laisse planer l'ombre de
l'assassinât politique
alors j'ai commencé à mener une enquête
j'ai joué le rôle de la police
scientifique et faute de pouvoir
prélever les empreintes des suspects
puisqu'ils ne sont plus là j'ai prélevé
les indices et les empreintes que je
trouvais dans les textes de la tradition
j'ai accumulé au terme de cette enquête
une masse considérable de notes un jour
en essayant d'y mettre de l'ordre
je me suis dit ah j'ai de quoi faire un
livre là et voilà que le besoin de lire
l'histoire de l'islam s'est transformé
en besoin de l'écrire de la réécrire
précisément avec mes mots mes phrases
pour mieux me l'approprier en somme
ma démarche ressemble un peu à celle des
salafistes
eux aussi ils s'approprient le passé et
met le passé au coeur
présents mais à la différence que moi je
place le passé au coeur du présent non
pas pour le vénéré mais pour
l'interroger
les salafistes regarde le passé avec les
lunettes roses de la légende
moi je le regarde avec un microscope
pour moi l'histoire ne doit pas être un
objet de culte mais un objet de
connaissance et cette connaissance que
j'ai fini par construire autour des
derniers jours de mohamed m'a révélé une
chose très importante à mes yeux c'est
que l'image meetic la représentation
mythique et dialysés que nous avons de
l'islam des origines et d'un mensonge
le constat le plus accablant que j'ai
fait est que la violence dans l'histoire
de l'islam n'est pas un phénomène
conjoncturel mais structurel ce qui
m'avait le plus choqué c'est que le
prophète a sans doute été lui même
victime de cette violence
le premier khalifa a été instauré suite
à un véritable coup d'état et il a été
inauguré par un bain de sang le premier
khalife a tout de suite déclaré une
guerre sans merci à tous ceux qui ont
contesté son autorité voilà qui
déconstruit l'image d'un âge d'or de
l'islam et de ses pieux ancêtres un sell
off salle dont se réclament les
salafistes dh en instituant le prétendu
état islamique ne fait en fait que
répéter les origines tragique de ce
premier khalifa qui a été édifiée au
prix d'un massacre alors quand on évoque
cette question de la violence endémique
au coeur de l'histoire de l'islam
j'ai constaté qu'il y a deux sortes de
réactions
il y a d'un côté une réaction
majoritaire celle du déni
ce n'est pas l'islam ce n'est pas nous
motion thê-anh et il y a à l'opposé la
réaction des intégristes qui glorifie
cette violence la célèbre et veulent la
perpétuer sans cesse d'engins dans un
geste de répétition compulsive moi je
pense qu'il ya entre les deux réactions
une posture intermédiaires qui est la
mienne qui consiste à assumer cette
histoire tout en la tenant à distance
tout en la prenant pour ce qu'elle est
un temps révolu qui doit être soumis à
l'analyse et à la lecture critique et il
vous dira que les textes de la tradition
musulmane se prête volontiers à cet
exercice de la lecture critique c'est
vrai ses textes sont un outil de
légitimation de la violence et du
fanatisme
mais quand on regarde de près on
constate que ces textes contiennent à la
fois le poison est l'antidote
il suffit simplement de retourner l'armé
textuelle et de prouver par les mêmes
textes que cette utopie d'un islam pur
parfait absolue porté par une
institution politico-religieuse
infaillible le califat est une
gigantesque imposture
c'est vrai les mouvements politico
religieux ont toujours confisqué le
passé et falsifier l'histoire
ils ont figé
la tradition ils l'ont momifié pour la
manipuler à leur guise et gardé par là
même un contrôle sur les esprits moi
j'ai essayé d'arracher les textes de la
tradition des mains de ces manipulateurs
et je pense que chacun de nous à son
échelle doit faire ce travail c'est vrai
il fut un temps où les textes de la
tradition était difficile d'accès est
jalousement gardé mais maintenant ce
n'est plus le cas franchement on n'a
plus aucune excuse
souvent quand je rencontre mes lecteurs
ils me font part de leur étonnement
devant les révélations qu'ils ont trouvé
dans mon livre
ils me disent mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on
nous a raconté et je leur dis toujours
assez facile allez vérifier vous même
dans les sources
construisez votre jugement comme dit
montaigne je crois qu'il faut qu'on
rompe définitivement avec cette paresse
intellectuelle qui nous empêche d'aller
nous mêmes vers les textes fondateurs de
l'islam
chaque période historique a le devoir
d'investir sa tradition pour la relire
et la réécrire le xvième siècle comme
vous le savez a été surnommé le siècle
de la renaissance
alors qu'il a été déchirée par les
guerres de religion or si on l'appelle
renaissance c'est parce que pendant ce
siècle
quelques hommes en décidé de lire
autrement les livres des anciens par ce
geste salvateur
ils ont changé le monde moi je pense que
il y a deux sortes dans d'authentiqués
révolution il y a les révolution
copernicienne celles qui font avancer la
science de savoir
et il y a les révolutions individuel ntm
que chacun accomplit en lui même les
deux révolutions les deux sortes de
révolutions sont libératrices et change
notre vision du monde
moi j'estime que j'ai commencé à peine
cette révolution individuels entre m
et je suis sorti complètement
métamorphosé de cette expérience de
lecture réécriture de l'histoire de
l'islam
kelly landis de cette métamorphose
eh ben je n'ai plus peur et du coup je
me sens plus libre
nombreux sont les gens autour de moi qui
me disent mais tu es seul tu t'attaques
à des sujets pareil tu n'as pas peur
comptes tu es là je leur réponds
toujours je n'ai pas peur de mourir
par contre ce qui me fait vraiment peur
c'est de vivre sans comprendre
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]